so in the midst of the FBI raid of
Donald Trump's Mar-A-Lago home and the
right wing going apoplectic to try to
figure out how can we attack what what
happened here today
Eric Trump
not known as Trump's smartest child but
that's okay Eric Trump goes on Fox News
and is so visibly triggered that he
doesn't even know what he's saying first
starting with the epitome of the
victimhood that the trumps are the
biggest victims in the United States you
know they went after him they went after
all of us there's no family in American
history that has taken more arrows in
the back
than the Trump family every single time
and right if you think of families who
have been destroyed by simply having
family members imprisoned due to having
drugs if you think of families who have
lost children in mass shootings if you
think of families who can't even afford
to feed their children no no no no no no
it is the Trump family that has been the
most victimized of any family then Eric
Trump pulling everything out of the Hat
bringing up Benghazi and going back to
Hillary there's a lot of things how
about the Benghazi scandals how about
the Clinton Foundation I mean how many
you know Shady oligarchs from Russia
were contributing to that look about how
about uranium one you want to talk about
you know scandals that were never
investigated never vetted yeah you know
I remember was it eight was it 12
investigations into Benghazi Benghazi
was a tragedy it was horrible what
happened but Hillary's involvement was
investigated up and down she testified
under oath for eight hours something
Donald Trump has not done give me a
break Eric then goes on and says there
wasn't even anything in the safe that
they ransacked hey we get another
subpoena and they do it for one reason
because they don't want Donald Trump to
run and win again in 2024 and Sean
that's what this is about today to have
30 FBI agents actually more than that
descend on Mar-A-Lago give absolutely
you know no notice go through the gates
start ransacking in office ransacking a
closet you know they broke into a if you
didn't even have anything in the safe
now if there was nothing in the safe
that's almost more suspicious I'd be
wondering where was the stuff moved to
um then lastly Eric Trump saying where
are where did these FBI agents go anyway
Shady deals with everybody around the
world and by the way it's all on his
laptop for the whole world to see in his
own writing and his own words cooperated
by everybody where were these FBI agents
where where is everybody why are you so
Eric Trump highly triggered and making
no sense at all let's now allow some
time
to let this settle and develop we will
learn more about it and we will see
where it ultimately goes what I want to
ask you is do you believe this is
finally the Levee breaking do you
believe an indictment is coming let me
know find me on Twitter at dpacman the
only streaming service dedicated to
documentaries is curiosity stream our
longtime sponsor on curiosity stream you
will find the best selection of
documentaries better than any other
platform they've got the newest and most
critically acclaimed titles I've been
watching curiosity stream in my living
room I recently watched the six episode
series Inside the Mind of a con artist
I'm fascinated by scammers and cons and
how they get away with what they do
really great series that I can recommend
to you curiosity stream is always adding
new content they've got documentaries by
filmmakers we know and love but they
make it easy to find new independent
documentaries as well if you want to
absorb as much as you can curiosity
stream is for you if you want to retain
very little once you turn off the TV you
can also just relax with like a nature
documentary curiosity stream has those
two and with the special discount for my
audience you can get curiosity stream
for 15 bucks a year not not a month a
year that's under two bucks a month go
to curiositystream.com Pacman and use
the code Pacman the link is down below